I'm gonna go and get started thank you
everyone for coming I'm gonna make
myself a clock so I can know it this is
40 minutes Kristina Sarah okay so my
talk is understanding probabilistic
topic models by simulation mostly by
probabilistic topic models I mean lady
rashly allocation and let's see what
that is
so what is a topic model I don't know if
there's one single definition of topic
model that that has used but it's the
idea of trying to extract what topics a
collection of documents are talking
about using some sort of statistical
method so we'll see how a late and dear
Schley allocation defines a topic but
the idea is like summarizing a document
base or collection of documents based on
the topics that are discussed within
those documents and that's using just
topic and document in very natural terms
that's not using a minute it necessarily
any weird math sense so if you look at
Wikipedia you get this definition of
Layton DeRose Chile allocation like most
math on Wikipedia that's not super
useful unless you are familiar with the
ideas of these terms and maybe not even
then so I'm not going to bother with
that you could also look at it from a
statistical perspective and see a
generative model written in this sort of
form which to some people this might
make a lot of sense and if you spend a
lot of time in this world it doesn't
make sense and that's really great I
think to most people who don't have the
statistics training this is not really
helpful I would argue even less helpful
than statistics is plate models I don't
know anyone who really benefits from
plate models so
if Andres claps then I guess I'm correct
on that you can also just look at a
likelihood you know back to the
statistics again I think some people
spend a lot of time in this world and
this is a helpful way to think about the
problem you know but I think for the
analysts who actually cares about doing
some sort of data analysis on documents
which is often not the same set of
people who develop these models from a
statistical perspective this is just not
really a helpful way to look at this so
I spent a lot of time trying to
understand what's going on with Layton D
reallocation and similar models and
extensions of late inertial allocation
and I've really wrestled a lot with poor
explanations I've watched a lot of
tutorial videos I've read a lot of
papers and often come away come away
really confused and so what I'm
attempting to do here is present latent
garishly allocation as a model in a more
friendly framework for those who
understand python or can can read some
somewhat straightforward code really the
hopefully the one thing that i'm
assuming here is that you understand
just the basics of code and then you
also understand something about how
random numbers are generated and how you
sample from distributions I'm not going
to go into how that works but I'm just
going to be kind of assuming that the my
hope is I'm not contributing to the
great corpus of literature that confuses
these topics because I think there's
already too much of that out there all
right so we want to think we're gonna
start from just the basic ideas of
clustering data and move on from there
too late and irrational allocation
actually one more thing I wanted to say
before that what I'm not going to be
presenting on here is how to actually do
the statistical imprint on late inertial
allocation which is in some ways a whole
nother problem on its own so I'm going
to try and explain what the model is
what are the some
since the models making how does it
represent your data I'm not gonna say
explain how you actually are fit that
model to your data if that's what you
came here hoping to hear I really don't
mind if you get up and leave that but
that's the something were going to talk
about here
now unfortunately takes more than 40
minutes to to explain I think so here's
some some measurements from Fisher's
iris data so this is measurements from
two different kinds of viruses and if we
didn't know what which two kinds of
viruses this came from could we in an
unsupervised way divide up this data and
say well here are two different clusters
of this data so we could cluster and
what we might call the eyeball method
which is they look like there are two
modes let's draw a line between the
modes and see if that correctly clusters
our data something that just clusters
data and one dimension by dividing your
line dividing your data into a line is
going to be what we would call the
discriminative model it's just going to
separate your data into two classes it
doesn't actually tell us anything or
make any well not telling us for example
what kind of distributions the data
might have come from I was gonna say it
doesn't make any assumptions about the
distribution of your data but that's
probably not true so in reality these
are the two classes of data from that
that Fisher collected so we could start
to think in what is going to be called a
generative model which is can we say we
didn't know this information but can we
make some assumptions about how the data
might have been generated or what
distributions might have been generated
the data so a Gaussian mixture model
which you've probably seen you can do a
Gaussian mixture model with like PI MC
or in Psych it is assuming that each
cluster of your data is generated from a
Gaussian distribution and you're trying
to by doing inference on the model
you're trying to say what which Gaussian
distributions were these clusters
generated from so instead of just trying
to separate the data we're trying to
model how the data has been generated
so we could simulate the generative
process for the data in Python and this
is going to be a core of a lot of what
I'm talking about here and I'm trying to
my goal here is to build this up into
being able to simulate late and dear
Ashley allocation so we could assume the
mixture proportions for our data are
50/50 so 50% of the data goes into one
cluster and 50% into the other we could
also assume that the data have these
means and these standard deviations and
then we could just write some Python
code to sample data points from these
distributions so we want to generate 100
data points and for each data point
we're going to flip a coin essentially
and decide which type of virus it is and
then we're gonna generate the sepal
length from a normal distribution we're
assuming that the state it came from a
normal distribution and so this is just
using sy pi to fill in the mean and
standard deviation and then I'm just
appending it to a list and so we could
plot that data and we get something that
looks maybe a little bit like that data
we saw previously which go back look
like this
so we're trying to in some way replicate
this data set by generating it from a
normal for normal distributions as we
move this into a bayesian context
instead of just having the mixture
proportion mean and standard deviation
be fixed values we often are going to
represent those things as distributions
themselves so the mixture proportions
how how many points go into each class
we can model as a deer Schley
distribution a deer filet distribution
is a you can think of as a distribution
over like discrete probability
distribution so in the in the
two-dimensional case it's like a draw
from the derailer distribution is going
to be like generating a weighted coin
where the weight can vary the sample is
corresponds to the weight and then our
mean and
standard deviation themselves we're
gonna draw from a normal distribution so
we're doing the exact the for loop here
is exactly the same except that instead
of starting with these hard-coded
distributions we're going to use ones
that we we drew from this dear chalet
and normal distributions and we could
again generate data which looks
different from the data we generated
previously because the parameters we put
into the model are different if we run
this exact same code again we're going
to get different samples so this time
it's going to look like this the idea
being that in a sense you could think of
this histogram being itself a sample
from a distribution and each time we run
this thing we're getting a different
histogram we're sampling a different
histogram so if we this is what we just
described is a generative model for
clusters you're saying data could be
generated by this process into two
Gaussian clusters and so if we want to
then have some data and fit the model to
the to that data we could sort of
reverse this process which is given some
data we don't know which clusters it's
in for each point we want to find which
cluster it's in and then potentially we
want to find those parameters the
mixture proportions or the parameters on
the the mean and standard deviation so
that's what that is in itself a whole
other talk as to how you could actually
go about that but that's how we use a
generative model to fit some data so you
can do this with PI MC I actually have a
notebook where I walk through a lot of
the math as to how that that works and
if you're interested it and you can look
at that or talk to me alright so I say
there's nothing inherently special about
the normal distribution okay that's
actually an utter lie other than in the
case of a generative model like this we
don't have to just sample from a normal
distribution for our data we could
sample from any distribution
so in here instead of sampling
continuous values from a normal
distribution I'm in a sample a snake
panda or bar chart from just this
discrete distribution of three items so
we're like flipping a three-sided coin
or rolling a three sided die or
something if you could imagine a
dimension where that would be feasible
so in this case I'm going to say with a
30% chance you go into to one cluster
and a 7% chance you go into the other
cluster I have three cluster is my mic
oh I just need to keep my head forward
sorry I have three clusters here
rejection I think might be a mistake
because I'm only talking about two
different clusters but what I'm going to
be doing here is the exact same thing so
for each data point I want to generate a
cluster by flipping this biased coin so
the coin is either 30% or 70% to one of
the other side and then I want to draw a
data point from the cluster distribution
corresponding to that cluster so if I go
to the 30% one I'm going to choose this
first distribution which is here the 70%
one I'm going to choose the second
distribution then I guess what you could
say with zero probability choose to the
third one
and then I can sample my snake panda or
bar chart from that distribution so
these are distributions over these three
items so we can run that and then get
some data which might look like this so
our first cluster is going to have a
bunch of snakes and a few pandas and a
bunch of bar charts the second cluster
is all a handful of snakes and then all
the rest pandas so the first one is
about 30% of the data points and the
second one is about 70% of the data
points so you could again say well given
these clusters could I if I didn't know
which clusters my data points were in
could I go back and figure that out as
the imprint step we're going to ignore
that for the time being except we
say we could again do this in Bayesian
fashion instead of hard-coding those
distributions we could sample those
distributions from the dear Schley
distribution so mixture proportion and
cluster distributions are again just
going to be fixed effects vectors
representing these probability
distributions except that we're drawing
them from the dear Schley distribution
so we could again generate some
documents in this case our first cluster
is really small it's one snake and the
second cluster is all the rest of the
data points down here okay so this model
in itself actually isn't super useful
but this is sort of an intermediate step
between what we call a Gaussian mixture
model and lady reallocation all right
I'm going to take a quick little break
here and talk about what we call the
bag-of-words assumption so if we go back
and think about these clusters as being
words which is what we're actually
starting to model we're starting to
model discrete things which could be
emoji or they could be words it turns
out the order in which these were
generated is completely irrelevant this
model knows nothing at all about the
order in which we generated them so if
we tried to do inference on this model
we could shuffle around the order of our
snakes and pandas and and bar charts and
the model is not going to care that
maybe make sense with emoji but if we're
talking about words that's that starts
to be important so this maybe looks
familiar beautiful is better than ugly
explicit is better than implicit simple
as better than complex this is the
design of Python well what we're saying
by the bag of words assumption is that
this string is exactly equivalent to
this string AAA although although
although ambiguity and our arc while
reading that that that appears to not be
nearly as meaningful but that is an
assumption that you're making in Layton
dear Ashley allocation model
I'm actually confused I gonna come back
to that hopefully that's not in the
place I bought it I wanted it to be
alright so I'm gonna move on from
sampling from just two different
clusters of data to what I'm going to
call sampling documents of data or what
statisticians might also call grouped
data so here I still have my same
vocabulary of snakes pandas and bar
charts and the number of terms is 3 I am
i boring vocabulary because matplotlib
doesn't handle emoji very nicely yet and
then i'm also going to create something
that I'm gonna call topics and I have a
sunny and a cloudy topic and what these
topics are gonna be our distributions
over my vocabulary so a topic is a
discrete distribution that when you like
draw a from your topic you're drawing a
word and that's actually how late endear
Schley allocation is going to understand
what a topic is it's just a topic is a
distribution over words so if you say my
document is about this topic what we're
in gonna mean by that is the words have
the probability of coming from this this
distribution finally I'm going to have a
mixture proportion which describes the
probability of or the proportion of
documents being of each topic all right
so now okay so my I'm gonna have about
70% of my documents being about clouds
and 70% being about the topic sunny and
within those topics I have a
distribution over words so the quality
topic is mostly involves the word snake
or the emoji snake the that is not
actually there's not a really a
connection there necessarily the sunny
topic is going to be about bar charts
and pandas primarily
all right so again I can describe this
generative model that generates topics
so for each document and this time the
first thing I'm going to do is flip a
coin and choose a topic that the
document is about then I'm going to
generate the length of the document from
a Poisson distribution and then I'm
going to generate the topic by looking
at the district each word in the
document by looking at the topic and a
topic is simply a distribution over
words so the this unfortunately is a
little bit the line break didn't mess up
but I'm going to create my documents by
drawing a word from that distribution of
words which is what we call a topic for
every word in the document so this gives
me five documents about cloudy which are
cloudy remember is mostly about snakes
and five documents about Sun or sunny
which is mostly about pandas and bar
charts all right so those are those are
the documents that I that I generated so
this is what we could call a topic model
we could then feed a bunch of documents
and we could instead of using emoji we
could use words and then we could say
what are the topics that each that the -
what are the topics that each document
is about and for each topic how are the
words distributed within that topic this
is not quite late and dear Schley
allocation however and the reason for
that is in Lane dear Schley allocation
we want to have documents be able to be
composed of multiple topics instead of
it what we're describing here which is a
document is composed of a single topic
all right but before we get to the
Layton garishly allocation we could this
is basically what I just said given a
collection of documents we want to find
the topic that corresponds to each
document and that's what essentially
what if you have read any of this
literature you've probably heard about
latent variables that means
each document corresponds to a topic we
just don't know what it is yet lateness
means basically we don't know what it is
yet so we want to find that latent
variable using a statistical inference
method and then for each topic we want
to figure out how the oh sorry also we
want to know what's the distribution
over topics across all the documents and
for each topic we want to know what that
topic is and remember we defined a topic
to just be a distribution over words so
like a weighted incited die that each
side of the die corresponds to to a word
we want to figure out what are the
weights on that die all right so this
has some limitations as we already said
we have a single topic per document that
is a big limitation if you just think
about how you know books or reports
anything they tend to be about multiple
topics as we already said we're assuming
that the word order is irrelevant
unfortunately that's not going to get
any better for the time being and it's
also going to assume that we know the
number of topics that we're looking for
in this particular model we're making
that a fixed assumption all right so
maybe we can deal with this first issue
which is a single topic per document
what if we sample the topic for each
word so I'm gonna recycle my topics
variable that we already generated which
are distributions over words for each
topic but now I want to generate my
document by I want to generate 10
documents and for each document I'm
going to generate its length which is
duck length I want to generate the
mixture proportion which is going to be
how the topics are mixed within the
document so I want my document to be
about a mixture of topics and this is
going to be a discrete distribution over
the topics which is two-dimensional we
have two topics so two-dimensional and
now for each word in my document I'm
going to have a two step process the
first step is
to generate a topic for my document and
so that's just like a an integer
corresponding to a topic and we we draw
that from these known fixed to topics we
already have and then for each topic I
then need to draw a corresponding word
all right so to really reiterate what's
going on here for each document I need
to decide how long the document is a
sample that from a random distribution I
need to decide how the topics are
distributed within the document and then
for each of these words course going up
to the document length I need to
generate a talking a topic for the
document I'm sorry a topic for the word
and that topic is simply a distribution
over words that's what this word dist is
going to be the reason for this being
two lines is random dot choice
can't sample from a list of lists it can
only sample from a list of integers
basically and so then I need to choose a
word from that topic and then so I'm
going to append that word to my document
so this right here is what we call a
generative process for Layton dear
Ashley allocation so when we talk about
Lda we're saying we're assuming that the
documents were looking at are generated
according to this process so we could
run that and then get a bunch of
documents so document number one has
some words from topic sunny and some
words from topic cloudy cloudy here is
mostly it appears again about snakes
actually we carried that over from
before so that still remains true and
the topic sunny is mostly about pandas
and bar charts but in each
document we see that the document length
can vary and also the way the topics are
distributed within that document can
vary some some documents like four is a
nine or only about one topic everything
else is about a mixture of topics now
you can look at this and say that
doesn't really look like a document well
one reason it might not look like a
document is because it's emoji not words
well we could replace the emoji with
words and then it'd be something you
could read the other reason is I'm kind
of grouping my words or emojis into
these two different rows as to how what
topics they're generated for that
doesn't really look like sentences well
if you made that observation that's
that's really good observation because
Layton garishly allocation knows nothing
at all about sentences that's a it's a
meaningless concept for Layton dear dear
Ashley allocation on top of that you
could shuffle the order of these around
if you look back at how these things are
generated they were generated
independently of one another so you
could like parallel why's that and they
could come out at any order whatsoever
and again that's exactly true Layton
dear Schley allocation doesn't know
anything about the order of these things
alright so this is sort of a weird form
in which to write documents but that
hopefully is indicative to you about
about what we're actually assuming or
what this model can even recognize so
there is one really subtle thing here
that is ends up being very powerful
thing about Layton garishly allocation
probably a lot of you have seen this
that Buffalo buffalo Buffalo buffalo
Buffalo buffalo Buffalo buffalo is a
grammatically correct English sentence
this is like a like a diagram parse tree
of the sentence structure you can look
at there's a Wikipedia page about it
under that name something that's really
subtle about Leighton deer actually
allocation after the the reservations I
just gave about some of its limitations
is that
a word in Layton D reallocation doesn't
have a one-to-one correspondence with
the topic so a given word such as
Buffalo could be generated by multiple
different topics so in theory if you had
rich enough data Lane tier so the
allocation could look at this and
recognize that these are not all the
same word even though they look exactly
the same and recognize that they come
from different topics essentially like
that so one of the uses of the word
Buffalo in here is the city Buffalo and
now there's the animal and it might be
able to figure out that those are
separate things so that's somewhat of a
subtle point but it ends up being an
important point that sets Lda apart is
over maybe a more naive method for
finding topics all right
so given that generative process I just
described what we then want to be able
to do for Leighton deer shalay a
location inference is given a collection
of documents so we know the words and
the documents those are known to us we
don't know what topics the the words
come from or what topics the dot are in
each document so our inference step is
for each document and then for each word
in that document we want to find what
topic generated that word and for each
topic how how are words this distributed
across that doc sorry for each document
how are the topics distributed across
the document so what topics - the words
in the document come from and for each
topic how are the words or terms
distributed for that topic so this is
the question of statistical inference on
late interior allocation and so if you
go and look at LD a and something like
mallet or gents M or the Python LD a
module this
is what that's trying to accomplish
which is feed it some documents tell me
what are the parameters that generated
those documents but the whole goal of
what I'm trying to communicate here is
when you're getting those parameters out
of the model you need to be careful that
you understand what parameter what what
you're talking about parameterizing what
what model how do you interpret those
things and what you need to interpret
them as or as parameters to this
generative model and so then when you
try and make sense of those and look at
your data and ask questions of what
those parameters might mean for you in
in taking action or something like that
one thing you need to be really careful
about is that you're not reading into
them that they're doing something that
they're not doing because in some ways
this is a very complex thing but in
other ways as you saw we're making a
really really naive assumptions about
where our documents come from we're
really just flipping some coins some in
sighted coins and generate in generating
documents and maybe some people in here
will well wonder if my whole talk has
been just generated by flipping in sided
coins but in reality that's not how we
communicate as humans that we we think
about our language is a lot more
complicated in that so while this is
very complex on some level it's also an
extremely simplistic look at language
alright so you can do this inference
with mathematically with Gibbs sampling
or other MCMC methods or with
variational inference and there are
various implementations of that
available online so we dealt with the
issue of a single topic per document we
didn't deal with the fact that this
leaves word order as being irrelevant
Hannah Wallach her dissertation was on
this this very topic you can look that
up
there's
in my opinion the theoretical work on a
lot of this stuff has progressed a lot
faster than any practical
implementations have so I don't know a
lot of practical implementations
implementing her ideas it also assumes
that we know the number of topics I
didn't really well on that a whole lot
but when you go to use one of these
libraries you're saying you have to tell
ahead of time how many topics it's
looking for that's a huge assumption
that you know like in k-means if you
want to extend the model beyond that the
main way to do that is with something
called a hierarchical D relay process I
actually have an implementation of
what's called HDPE Lda on it's available
through Conda and so on github if you're
interested in using that you should come
talk to me first it's just it's a very
mathematically very difficult thing to
do so it's something that makes a lot of
sense in theory that and reality ends up
being extremely hard to do there are
other limitations of the of an Lda model
just the day I discovered something I
don't think I've seen before ooh bad
mark down here but David blye who who
has done a lot of the foundational
research on this stuff wrote an
unusually excellent clear review of
probabilistic topic models for the
communications the ACM in 2012 if you're
interested at all in using Lda Moore
after having heard this talk I would
really go read his paper and think about
some of the limitations that he talks
about there if you want to try to do Lda
in Python gen sim is one that a lot of
people know about I have not had great
success in actually using it but Allen
riddle
he's a riddle on Twitter and on github
he has a package called Lda that is a
siphon implementation so it's relatively
fast it's really easy to use fairly low
overhead pip installable I really
recommend that I said in my abstract I
was going to talk about visualization
which I'm not doing but also if you're
doing this stuff you should look at
pi L da vis by Ben maybe also PIP
insoluble to other resources I would
point you to our Edwin Chen has maybe
something analogous to this talk I'm
giving on his blog introduction to light
and irrational allocation it's a really
helpful read finally if you're
interested in the math as to how you
actually do the inference finding
scientific topics by Thomas Griffiths
and Marx Stivers is a good resource to
get going on that I have no idea how I'm
doing on time but I will happily field
questions it's almost 5:00
hey thank you for the talk other than
classifying documents into clusters what
are some other practical applications
for topic modeling yeah so well saying
that you're assuming that it's a
practical practical application is
clustering documents which is debatable
but people have extended this to apply
to images I don't know a whole lot about
that but that's a I think a really
interesting area of sort of finding
topics and images which are sort of the
scenes that make up an image at least
all the theoretical research talks about
how it's going to be useful in like
genetics and various things
I know literally nothing about that like
just the whole realm of genetics but
sort of finding patterns and DNA or
various things like that there's some
people here are actually using Lda to
find sort of cluster binary files you
guys here yeah in the back who I was
talking to yesterday and I'm just really
something I had never thought about but
sort of for malware detection yes that
awful
yeah other practical applications for
Lda and text analysis so I'm not really
an expert on that and one thing that one
answer I could give to you is one way
you can look at this is actually a load
low dimensional representation of
documents if you just think about how if
you think about your how each how each
document what the distribution of topics
is for each document so say you have 10
top topics you have this essentially a
unit vector or probability vector
describing the distribution of topics
for each document and so you can think
of that as actually like projecting your
documents into this 10 dimensional space
and you can actually end up coming up
with some there's some really
potentially interesting things of taking
documents being these like ragged arrays
or like really somewhat unstructured
data into this lower dimensional space
that hopefully describes some sort of
behavior of the document and then you
can maybe think about feeding that that
is like a pre-processing step towards
other algorithms yeah hey well yeah I
don't have a whole lot more to say now
someone had the microphone
is it possible to assume a correlation
between topics so that's a really good
observation that there's like a whole
lot of independence being assumed in
this model if you talk to the people who
sort of develop these kind of
unsupervised Bayesian models they just
love to talk about how extremely easy it
is like extend the models or embed them
in more complex models or all these
different things the problem is the math
for actually doing inference on the
models is obscenely difficult and so I
want another way to look at that it's
like in some sense you could describe
any generous you could describe make
your generative model arbitrarily
complex right the problem is how do you
then reverse that and and do inference
on that and so I'm sure there are papers
talking about like correlations between
your topics but the people who are
developing that never provide any decent
implementations to actually do the
inference so yes and no maybe it's the
answer to that this is a really very
frustrating thing if like you've tried
to work on that boundary little bit of
theory in practice yes I have a question
about so you can apply the model to any
kind of set of document even though the
documents can have no topic of structure
so how do you know what how well the
model is working on any set like do you
have any metrics yeah so how do you know
how well the the models are working the
best thing I know of is you look at your
topics and see if they appeared to tell
you something meaningful that might be
relevant to your data I mean I think
outside of the having some human
knowledge of the what might make sense
and that's a really hard hard question
and I mean you could try to come up with
some various metrics just like you could
with like k-means
for example but it's somewhat
analogously it's like it's I guess
ultimately how well it's working is a
somewhat subjective thing and so you
kind of have to evaluate it on those
terms I think but okay we run out of
time you can just applause thank you
you